Qué es lo que está en juego en Estados
Unidos esta noche
Buenas noches Santiago y los
televidentes de Francia 24 este es una
lección sumamente importante y va a
determinar el destino de la presidencia
de yopain por los próximos dos años
Ahora históricamente
siempre el partido que no estaba en
poder gana escaños en las elecciones de
los miltons entonces normalmente en la
cámara de representantes se centra el 20
y 40 escaños depende de la popularidad
del presidente entonces podemos esperar
como explicó en el de 538 casi seguro
que los republicanos van a tomar control
de cámara de representantes el campo de
batalla más importante Entonces es el
senado ahora el 5050 y hay tres o cuatro
estados que va a determinar el destino
del senado Durante los próximos dos años
de la presidencia
y vamos a esperar esas esos estados
claves para saber más allá cómo va a
quedar el senado ahora los temas más
importantes a favor de los republicanos
es la economía y la cuestión de
seguridad
y las cuestiones migratorias la gente
que tiene ese como si prioridad tiene
tendencia de estar a favor de los
republicanos la gente que está más
preocupado sobre el la democracia el
estado de democracia en los Estados
Unidos y los amenazas de contra las
instituciones y también que está más
interesados sentimos como aborto y la
ola conservadora de los Estados Unidos
ellos van a tener tendencia de votar
demócrata para los demócratas
en los últimos semanas el tema de
economía ha tomado control y por eso hay
mucha proyección que los republicanos
van a quedar esta noche